what's going on guys this is Rob and in
this video I'm gonna answer the question
with my 25 some odd years of comic book
knowledge if I were leading the charge
on Thor love and thunder meaning I was
the director I had total creative
control the buck stopped here right I
controlled every facet of the project
what would that movie look like and I
could tell you right now it wouldn't
look anything well maybe a little bit
like the movie that we got but it
wouldn't feel like the movie that we got
right so first things first in terms of
the tone of that film it would be dark
it would be a dark movie and I know a
lot of you guys are probably like really
man like coming out of infinity war in
Avengers endgame you would do another
dark film yes I'm not against phase four
having comedy and in fact I think we're
long overdue for that I think that we
needed a phase that focused more on the
comedic and lighthearted elements for
Thor this needed to be a dark film so
let's look at Gore the god butcher for a
second now let's talk about going the
god butcher when it comes to Gore in in
Thor love and thunder the motivation for
why he ended up becoming the being that
he was was not that this summer from the
comics the circumstances under which he
became the god butcher were different
but the motivation wasn't all that
different right in the movie you guys
know how he became Gore the god Witcher
in the movie right like his daughter
died and he finally went into the realm
of of his God right he met the god of
his people and the God just kind of
laughed at him and dismissed him and was
like your job is to suffer and die right
there's no heaven for you making fun of
him and that kind of a thing and then
Gore ends up getting the necro sword
which seems to basically be sentient
kind of have a life of its own and then
he kills the God and then decides that
all other gods across the cosmos needs
to need to die because reasons because
the plot called for it in the comics
it's a little more guttural right it's a
little more cerebral than that it's the
fact that Gore had basically prayed to
the gods alongside the tribe that he was
in that they prayed to the gods for rain
they prayed to the gods for sustenance
and sometimes they would answer
sometimes they wouldn't but that Gore
basically came to believe that Gods
didn't exist right when he lost his
family he was like the gods aren't real
because if gods were real and gods did
love us they wouldn't have us living in
this terrible environment he was
ultimately outed by his people literally
kicked out of their nomadic tribe and
then he came across the body of two gods
and realized gods are real now
technically one of them was Nola
symbiote God but that's neither here nor
there you know he basically came to the
realization that gods are real and the
suffering that he and his people endured
and the loss of his family was because
like hey the gods just don't really care
or maybe they like messing with you
whatever it is the gods don't care about
people so the motivations between the
comic and the film aren't really all
that different with the movie I would
have totally changed the entire
motivation behind the gore the god
butcher because of the circumstances
involving Infinity war and Avengers
endgame I would have totally switched it
up instead of Gore being from like some
desolate world where life was really
really harsh what I would do is I would
change things up to where the planet he
was on was basically fine and had a
governing body and it had a culture and
people were fed and watered and
everything was great and maybe they were
more of like a religious culture than
anything else they were based more
focusing on their Godly beings and
praying to them and that kind of stuff
but life was for the most part just kind
of a Utopia but when Thanos snapped his
fingers and blinked out half the life in
the universe half their population
vanished and what was a societal Utopia
albeit based on a theocracy gave way to
religious zealotry suddenly his the
people who were left were like we've
angered the gods somehow we need to
sacrifice people in order to to make
this work but I know it seems kind of
weird but it's not that far of a stretch
in times of desperation people will
believe what they want to believe and so
literally Gore the god witcher's family
are some of those people who are
sacrificed and he has to watch as that
happens now where you would expect him
to turn his anger towards the people who
sacrificed his family the question that
he finds himself asking is where are the
Gods in all this right like what's like
if the you know the gods that we believe
in why didn't they protect us why didn't
they protect my family or anything along
those lines the other thing here is by
whatever Manner and whatever means the
all-black necro sword comes to gore I
don't know but Gore ends up finding his
God the god of his planet and the God
tells him it's because Thanos over on
Earth writes some Backwater World
whatever it is blinked out half life in
the universe or whatever it is and the
result of this is that half the
universe's population is vanished and
your people have basically gone insane
and started sacrificing people to me but
the God tells Gore this in a way where
he basically acts the same way that God
did in the movie where he's dismissive
if anything it's actually kind of a
source of entertainment I love watching
how your people just go crazy right and
where this guy is sort of laughing and
finding some measure of entertainment
over the fact that Gore's entire family
was killed the gore lashes out and kills
that God Gore then turns his attention
to traveling across the cosmos and he
ends up finding out it's happening on
every world every World across every
Galaxy and every solar system in some
form or fashion has descended into
madness and Chaos now this is an
incredibly important plot Point not just
for Gore the god butcher but for Thor
himself because with all of this going
on eventually Gore would turn his
attention to omnipotent City he would
learn that there is a council of gods
that meet how ever often and he would
literally go there right he would
beseech the gods and say like I want to
meet and speak with the gods and maybe
they for whatever reason they entertain
him I don't know it doesn't matter but
he would basically show up there and he
would literally challenge the gods and
ask where were all of you when Thanos
was dusting half the universe's
population why didn't you intervene why
didn't you step in why didn't you try to
stop Thanos right why is it that my
people half of our population were
killed they fell to religious zealotry
this world here fell that world here
fell the universe was crumbling and
falling and the people who were praying
to you were being ignored and the
response he gets it's basically exactly
how the gods acted in Thor love and
thunder that when you look at what Zeus
popped up and all that kind of stuff one
they meet in a giant Golden Temple
Zeus's introduction is flamboyant and
it's flashy and it's just over the top
clearly the gods have bought into their
own hype and and Gore sees that the gods
are dismissive the gods don't care and
so gore that's when he would make his
decision God's everywhere need to die
what's the point of having you here if
all you're going to do is ignore the
people who pray to you and refuse to
help them when you could now this is an
incredibly important plot point when it
comes to gore we'll talk about the whole
uh plot point with Thanos and the snap
and everything about Thor here in a
second but this is an incredibly
important plot point when it comes to
gore because this makes him relatable
because how many people you me anybody
else have experienced some kind of
situation where we've had a crisis of
Faith where our belief in whatever God
we believe in comes into question when
we just kind of look at our own
individual circumstances or the world
around us and say how kind could God
really be if this is how everything is
right if this is how this is the world
we live in how much could God really
care and when people you know you and me
and anybody else when we find ourselves
asking that question and then we see
Gore in this movie asking that exact
same question and then getting a
response by gods who were dismissive we
can totally understand his anger we can
totally understand in his wrath and
instead of gorgeous being some guy who's
pissy cause his daughter died he turns
into a guy that's relatable we almost
kind of want to cheer him on we don't
necessarily do it because we understand
the totality of what he would be doing
because in response to that he would
kill everybody in omnipotent City not
every single God some would Escape Zeus
might be powerful enough to survive and
just kind of Limp off to Olympus or
whatever it is but like he would just go
on a war path just killing Gods across
omnipotent City and that right there
would solidify just how powerful Gore is
how powerful he's become using the
all-black necro sword and there'd be
small little things to indicate in
between why people you would like
literally he would walk in and you'd
hear you'd see Gods talking to each
other like the all black necro sword
holy [ __ ] how do you get that like that
kind of a thing you know like dude like
okay like we need to be worried and gork
would just lash out and kill everybody
now as far as Thor his journey would be
whatever his journey is with the
Guardians of the Galaxy until he starts
learning that like gods are being killed
coming up on corpses of dead Gods
different things like that kind of what
we saw in the movie but this is where
things get really really interesting is
that once he learns that Gore the god
butcher is the one behind it and once he
learns the motivation of Gore it catches
up to him and that's why the Thanos snap
is such an important plot point for Thor
because Thor has to come to grips with
this realization how foolish was it to
believe that because Bruce Banner
snapped his fingers and brought back
everybody who was dusted and Tony Stark
snapped his fingers and wiped out Thanos
and his forces the day saved and
everything's okay and and it's cool now
right every every all is forgotten right
like how foolish is it to believe that
how foolish was it to believe there was
no blowback that there were no lingering
effects for The Disappearance of half of
the universe's population that there had
to be instances out there when this was
going to somehow come back and this
affects Thor in particular why because
Thor didn't aim for the head that was
the entire plot point for his character
throughout the entirety of Avengers end
game and where you would have thought
that movie was him coming to terms with
the fact that he didn't aim for the head
and that Thanos was finally defeated he
now has to reconcile with the fact this
is just another thing piling on to the
guilt he feels because of the fact that
you know half the universe's population
was even dusted in the first place that
was the whole pain that he had to endure
half the universe was wiped out because
of him because of the fact that he
didn't kill Thanos when he could have
that was the motivation for why he
joined the team in the first place in
Avengers end game that's why he got fat
playing video games because he was just
depressed right and when when it was
just a moment when he could finally get
away from this when it was a moment when
he could finally come to terms with
everything now he has to deal with the
fact that there are consequences for
these actions to make things even more
complicated Thor travels to omnipotent
City saying okay gods are being killed
we need to have some kind of of a baby
huge coming together of the various Gods
when he gets there he finds a tomb right
he literally finds so many of these gods
have been killed by by Gore and so now
it's really just kind of down to him
maybe Jane Foster and valkyr a valkyrie
if you really want to throw him in there
but the reality here it's personal for
Thor because this is him having to deal
with all this and so when you have this
circumstance when he finally catches up
to gore which I never would have invoked
eternity as a wishing machine but just a
wishing statue with the center of the
universe I never would have done that
right like it would have just been Thor
versus Gore and this fight would have
been an emotional fight for Thor they
would have been a very very emotional
fight and the reason why is because
Thor's conflicted on one half he
understands why Gore is doing what he's
doing because he knows the gods and he
knows that a lot of those Gods out there
really are just dicks right they really
just don't care that he's one of the
very few Gods out there who actually
cares about Humanity but why is he a God
who cares about Humanity because he was
cast down from Asgard by Odin and forced
to live among Humanity that he has spent
his whole life removed from all things
in existence he hasn't spent his whole
life removed from the very people that
pray to him instead he's lived among
them so that ties back into the nature
of Thor which shows how far he's
progressed as a character over the
course of the last however long he's
been in the Marvel Cinematic Universe so
he understands to a degree where it is a
gorse coming from but at the same time
he can
should a guy traveling around the cosmos
killing every God he can find because
Thor knows it's only a matter of time
before Gore comes for him so ultimately
it's a fight between Thor and Gore and
it's literally one of these things where
like you don't know if Thor's gonna make
it out alive like you don't know if he's
gonna survive this whole thing you're
kind of like dude Thor might die here
man like this might be the end of Odin's
son now ultimately he does come out on
top and he does win but this is the most
important element when it comes to gore
this is the most important thing there
is no moment at the end of this movie
when Gore Witnesses Odin's son with Jane
Foster and Odin's son chooses love and
then Gore's heart grows three sizes
bigger and he sees the air of his ways
that doesn't happen that Gore is
irredeemable he can't be fixed he can't
be safe because he genuinely believes
all the gods have to die like the longer
he does this and the further along this
path he goes the less it becomes about
the gods don't care about people and the
gods have to go and the more it becomes
just desire to kill and we can literally
tie this into the fact that he's just
constantly being influenced by the necro
sword if we want to we can go any number
of ways to make this happen but the
overall gist is whatever path we choose
for this Corruption of Gore by the time
you get to the end of the movie there is
no saving him and and Thor tries Thor
tries to bring him back because it's
less about Thor trying to actually save
Gore and it's more about Thor trying to
exonerate himself trying to get rid of
this guilt and if he can save Gore then
it didn't mix up for everything dude it
makes up for the fact that he didn't aim
for the head and he can finally get rid
of this last bit of guilt but instead
bore can't be saved he can't be redeemed
there's no bringing him back and the
only option that Thor has is to kill
boar now I'm not saying the movie has to
be like has to end on a super Bleak note
they can in on some measure of a
positive a positive note I don't I don't
care what kind of note they ended on but
the overall significance of this is that
it is Thor having to come to terms with
the fact of accepting what happened him
having to accept the fact that he could
have aimed for the head and he didn't
aim for the head and what happened
happened and instead of trying to hide
from it instead of joining the Guardians
of the Galaxy and running away from it
Thor has to accept it that sometimes we
just don't do the right thing when we
could do the right thing and there are
consequences to be paid for that but
coming to terms with that and learning
to understand that and make peace with
the past that's just a part of living
and so that's how I would have handled
that film The pacing and everything I
think it had a little too much comedy
right I mean you know I mean it can have
some comedic elements right I mean it
doesn't have to be like an overly dark
story but that's what this would be it
would be Thor it would it would be Gore
the god torture being the main villain
of the story but it would basically be
Thor having to come to terms with it it
would be one of the incredibly rare
instances in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe when I'm actually okay with a
villain dying because the villain of
Borah has less to do with Gore being
Gore and it has more to do with Thor's
journey and coming to peace with his
Journey for dying that's fine right in
this instance I'm okay with that I do
have ideas where Gore should live and
and all in all honesty I'm not overly
against gourd living but I think in this
instance because the movie would be more
about Thor's Journey Gore should
probably die at the end but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end let me know what you
think down in the comment section thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later
peace